we're going to take a quick tour through
sort of a new level of depravity for
radical republican congresswoman
marjorie taylor green and she's as
disgusting as she is hypocritical
remember all of marjorie taylor green's
my hipaa stuff where somebody would ask
her hey
are you vaccinated and she would go well
that's my hipaa and of course it wasn't
hipaa relates to the transmission of
medical data by medical professionals
and providers and insurance companies
and associated organizations if a
reporter goes hey are you vaccinated it
doesn't violate hipaa but
we now have marjorie taylor green
sharing the medical information of a
child now we're going to look at an
article from lgbtq nation there's
nothing
really concerning in what i'm going to
show you uh but there are like sort of
very mild medical pictures that are
going to come up as part of what
marjorie taylor green tweeted just as a
heads up
marjorie taylor green shares child's
medical photos in bizarre anti-trans
rant it's not clear the congresswoman
even knows what the photos show
but she's sure they show a minor and she
shared the pictures anyway okay
marjorie taylor green shared pictures of
one or more miners on twitter in order
to attack the family of a possibly
transgender young person
this child is not old enough to vote buy
cigarettes or watch an r-rated movie but
they let her choose to have them cut her
breast off
she wrote while sharing a tweet with two
pictures
one of the pictures shows a girl in her
early teens fully dressed
the other shows a young person in their
late teens or early 20s shirtless after
what happens what appears to be a double
mastectomy
my protect children's innocence act will
stop this she wrote referring to a bill
she introduced last month
green retweeted anti-trans activist
chloe cole who wrote real reality check
nothing is okay about this okay so the
pictures are here okay there's there's
really nothing there's almost nothing
that we can see here um on the left
again it's a picture of
what appears to be a young woman and
then on the right you can't even really
tell if it's the same person you you
can't really tell anything about it
there's someone with with band-aids over
their nipples
and um
there's a scar and there could have been
a double mastectomy there it we don't
even really know who this is or what it
is but marjorie taylor green's belief
is that it's all the same person and
that at least in some of these pictures
maybe all this individual is a minor now
what's called gender affirming surgery
is not performed on minors rights lgbtq
nation in fact the off-repeated claim
was rated false by politifact
nevertheless the idea that children's
hospitals are performing gender
affirming surgeries on young children
has gained traction on the far right
leading to harassment and death threats
against pediatricians okay i don't even
care about that part because we've
covered that part before
this is not
a hipaa issue what marjorie taylor green
did here is not a hipaa issue hippa
relates to medical professionals and
related organizations sharing
information about patients
but if marjorie taylor green is
concerned with medical privacy
to the point where when she's asked by a
journalist
are you vaccinated she goes that's my
hipaa you don't get to ask me that
then she really should care about this
this should be wrong based on her own
apparent moral compass there is no such
thing as a low
below which this woman will not stoop
she's a horrible person
i hope
that there are consequences for this
these people offer nothing substantive
and as we talked about earlier in the
show
when lauren bober
during her debate against her opponent
in colorado
mentioned nancy pelosi's con job a dozen
times part of it is
that stuff works to some degree with
their electorate because their
electorate is so weaponized the other
part of it is
uh they don't actually have anything
substantive to offer marjorie taylor
green doesn't offer any policy
and um this is what you get when you put
these people in power retweeting
pictures
of individuals she believes are minors
we don't know that they're minors we
don't know the origins of the picture we
really don't know anything
but she believes that at least in one of
those pictures that individual is a
minor if it's even the same person in
both pictures and she still is
retweeting and amplifying it it's
absolutely horrifying